initié en mars 2009 l'opération
d'intérêt national au yen paris-saclay
concerne un vaste territoire allant de
saint quentin en yvelines à massy et
d'orsay à versailles au coeur de ce
projet porteur d'avenir
un pôle technologique et scientifique de
rang mondial qui allie ambitions
internationales et intérêts de la
population locale présentation opération
c'est cornélien paris saclay
non je devrais le savoir en plus y'a pas
un truc de métro les trucs comme ça
c'est pas pour monter en fait une une
je connais pas un endroit
ce possible plateau de saclay avec
toutes les industries qui s'y installent
une voie de communication pourrait créer
des pôles universitaires d'excellence
qui puisse finalement rivaliser avec des
campus qu'on trouve à l'étranger
notamment aux états unis
mettre des compétences
je dirais aussi bien en termes
universitaires qu'industriels on se
passe assez monteur impôts une espèce de
pôles de compétences c'est qu'ils
veulent mettre le métro sous terre au
lieu de commun avec oman au lieu de il
ya un truc comme ça j'ai vu un truc
comme ça
certes mais soyons un peu plus précis et
partons à la rencontre de pierre weiss
le président directeur général de
l'établissement public paris saclay qui
pourra nous en dire un peu plus sur
cette fameuse opération d'intérêt
national
c'est une opération qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre du grand paris et qui consiste
à développer spécifiquement cette partie
du sud ouest de paris qui est autour du
plateau de saclay en plateau agricole
avec quatre grandes intercommunalités
versailles saint quentin et au sud à la
caps et europe est seul et donc ils
représentent un potentiel à la fois
universitaire d'enseignement supérieur
et de recherche mais aussi économique
tout à fait exceptionnel en et de francs
et en france maintenant l'idée c'est le
moment d'en faire un pôle d'envergure
mondiale dans l'optique la silicon
valley aux états unis l'essor de
l'enseignement et de la recherche
amélioration des transports construction
de logements diversifiés le yen paris
saclay est effectivement un projet de
territoire ambitieux
d'ailleurs avec le futur campus paris
saclay l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'inscrira au
coeur d'un regroupement scientifique
inédit en france à cette échelle
on vit 30 école car ceux-ci cet
organisme de recherche à caractère
national et deux universités pas reçu
des nouvelles
nous sommes membres fondateurs de ce qui
est encore aujourd'hui il faut en
fondation de coopération scientifique
nous sommes également membre de l'idex
athée et là nous sommes partie prenante
de la création de l'université paris
saclay qui doit être inauguré si je puis
dire au 1er janvier 2014
je crois que nous avons à apporter à
cette construction à cette université
notamment parce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure nos caractéristiques en termes
de recherche également par des
disciplines telles que les humanités ne
sais pas sur le secteur de saclay donc
on beaucoup sur l'université de
versailles saint quentin pour avec sa
jeunesse dynamiser ce projet là on a par
exemple reproché sur l'automobile du
futur la mobilité du futur
le véhicule décarboné comme on dit
aujourd'hui l'université de versailles
votre contrat ou xing s'inscrit
totalement dans le projet université
paris sinclair qui devrait voir le jour
en 2014
car c'est important pour notre
université d'avoir une visibilité
interne à l'international mais également
pour nos laboratoires de recherche
d'être inscrit dans un projet innovant
qui devrait permettre des collaborations
avec des universités des grandes écoles
mais également des organismes qui
participent à ce projet c'est en cela
qu'il a un côté assez innovant puisque
généralement on n'a pas c'est trois
grands os qui travaillent ensemble
regrouper un peu les forces
universitaires qui sont très importantes
on a le premier pôle universitaire ici
de france deuxièmement booster le
développement économique en particulier
en ayant davantage de relations entre le
monde universitaire et non des
entreprises comme france et de montres
dans son petit peu à tignes aurait donc
en france qui est du potentiel et bien
sûr aussi il faut qu'elle profite aux
populations locales
ça profite évidemment d'abord dans la
création d'emplois
et puis aussi parce que ça va être
l'occasion d'aménager
ce territoire en terme de mobilité
interne aussi de développement de
l'habitat
notre idée de base c'est vraiment de
faire des opérations mixtes et dans
lesquels on a à la fois le développement
économique le développement
universitaire et le développement de la
ville
lorsque monsieur cadalbert appel à
kloster cité saint quentin et wind est
au coeur de l'opération d'intérêt
national paris saclay
cette convergence et rencontre entre
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche et
innovation est la source des emplois de
demain mais aussi l'équilibré équilibre
entre le logement les services publics
le cadre de vie la qualité de vie sur
notre territoire sont fondamentaux pour
obtenir effectivement un véritable
cluster plaster cité l'exemple de la
réussite de saint quentin est mis dans
son équilibre entre le développement
économique le cadre de vie le logement
les services publics et aussi la qualité
de son environnement et du bien vivre à
saint quentin guide doit servir
d'exemple pour le reste du plateau
saclay 50 à d'abord un très grand pôle
économique intégrant les gens ne savent
pas mais ça n'est plus principaux pôles
de d'emplois et d'entreprises notamment
de technologie un peu pointu aujourd'hui
relais de france donc ça va conforter ce
pauvre on espère que ça va permettre de
créer de nouveau de nouvelles
entreprises de nouveau de nouveaux
emplois améliorer la qualité de vie
urbaine tout en préservant très
soigneusement espaces agricoles espace
naturel parce qu'on sait bien que ça
fait partie de la qualité de vie que les
gens viennent chercher dans cette cette
région de l'île de france
pour cela il faut qu'on continue dans le
développement universitaire c'est ce
qu'on conduit on voit bien aujourd'hui
avec l'ouverture de notre pu faire
mission de la santé la fac simone veil à
saint quentin en yvelines mais aussi ce
qui est le plus important pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est développer des
transports en commun structurants
important on l'a fait déjà avec tcsp
transport en site propre qui devrait
rapidement se terminer entre massy et 50
en idées
et on attend bien sûr l'arrivée du métro
automatique du grand paris sur le même
tracé
les transports en commun est un élément
fédérateur entre l'est et l'ouest du
plateau de saclay de plus ils pas les
eaux jusqu'à est longue et maintenant
les accus du mois le 3 décembre dernier
l'ufr des sciences de la santé de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines a été inaugurée par marisol
touraine ministre de la santé et des
affaires sociales
à cette occasion la faculté de médecine
recevait une invitée de marque en la
personne de madame simone veil
l'ancien ministre de la santé notamment
auteur en 74 de la loi autorisant
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse a
donné son nom au bâtiment qui accueille
depuis la rentrée
1200 étudiants et 250 chercheurs en
épidémiologie et recherche
biomoléculaire 20000 c'est le nombre de
salariés qui travaillent pour la filière
automobile constructeurs équipementiers
distributeurs à saint quentin en
yvelines
cela représente près d'un cinquième des
102 mille salariés saint quentinois et
parmi eux certains ne manqueront pas de
se rendre au musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines qui propose une
leçon de rattrapage à tous ceux qui
n'auraient pas encore vu son expo
puisque celle-ci intitulée rêvant la
ville est prolongée jusqu'au 18 mars
l'occasion de découvrir est d'imaginer
en famille avec humour et de manière
interactive la ville de demain
le 20 décembre le conseil
d'agglomération a voté le budget
primitif 2013 de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines marqué par une
diminution des dépenses de
fonctionnement tout en assurant la mise
en oeuvre de la programmation
pluriannuelle des investissements
rappelons l'importance de cet outil quel
budget puisqu'il permet d'assurer la
solidarité communautaire à travers la
mise en oeuvre d'une politique publique
de qualité
un dossier que vous pouvez retrouver
ainsi qu'un zoom sur les petits ateliers
benjamin jardin enfants installés dans
une maison de retraite a dit montaigne
et un article sur la créatrice de mode
vie sinoise marie elodie poo royer dans
les petits content du mois de janvier
alors bonne année à tous et à bientôt
m